j'ai 14 ans nous sommes au mois de juin
1991 et je viens de finir le championnat
30 gymnastique ou avec mon équipe nous
venons de finir premières
ça fait dix ans que je rêve d'intégrer
l'équipe de france disons que je
m'entraîne 25 heures par semaine pour
cela et ça fait dix ans aussi que je
m'interroge sur pourquoi est-ce-que
alors que je sens que j'ai un certain
potentiel
je bloque au sens littéral du terme je
reste des heures et des heures sur une
poutre sans arriver à partir dans mes
figures mes entraîneurs s'arrache les
cheveux avec moi mais personne ne
comprend et là en ce mois de juin 1991
je vienne décidé qu'il était temps pour
moi d'arrêter cette aventure je suis sûr
bord de mer et j'échange avec linchuan
qui par la suite a été l'entraîneur de
l'équipe de france ekindi c'est vraiment
dommage quand même parce que tu avais
toutes les capacités physiques pour être
championne du monde
c'est là que deux cas pas suivi en une
phrase il a dit toute la frustration que
j'ai vécu toutes ces années vous savez
cette frustration n'utilisez votre
potentiel qu'à un dixième de vos
capacités
mais en même temps c'est cette
frustration qui m'apportez qui m'a amené
à murray à réfléchir et à me poser les
bonnes questions pour trouver là où je
pouvais déployer mon potentiel pour ça
j'évoquais du prg du professeur
d'éducation physique ont marketing la
communication passant par l'événementiel
j'ai même failli croire certains qui me
disait que j'étais instable mais au
final j'ai toujours écouté mon coeur
j'ai toujours été vain ce que j'avais
envie de faire et pas vrai ce que il
aurait fallu que je fasse et de ce
parcours là j'en ai retiré un constat
qui peut vous être utile
ce constat c'est que vous avez tout
intérêt à choisir le manager et le poste
qui vous correspondent
alors on peut y arriver assez
régulièrement à ça mais on peut aussi
comme tout change tout le temps très
vite se retrouver dans une des trois
autres situations vous pouvez voir ici
où on ne sait pas pourquoi on n'est pas
bien on est frustrés et on n'a pas les
clés pour en sortir et la l'étiquette de
nul apparaît on commence à être
stigmatisée
alors j'ai deux bonnes nouvelles pour
vous quand même la première bonne
nouvelle c'est que personne les nuls en
tant que tel la deuxième bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'en plus tout le monde est
excellent quelque part quand on se sent
nulle en général c'est parce qu'on n'est
pas dans un bon contexte pour pouvoir
exprimer le meilleur de soi pour arriver
à cela
à un moment donné il faut savoir se
poser et se poser les bonnes questions
pour cela j'ai mis au point un parcours
de réflexion que j'ai nommé le vasco le
vasco ces cinq éléments fondamentaux qui
sont importants à prendre en compte et
donc je vous invite à y réfléchir parce
que si l'un de ses éléments manquent
il y aura un moment donné frustration
vous serez pas bien vasco cv pour valeur
à pour actions efficientes
est-ce pour sens donner à ces actions
c'est pour le contexte et aux pour
l'objectif
alors commençons avec les valeurs les
valeurs c'est ce qui nous fonde c'est ce
sur quoi on s'est construit pensé à une
personne un personnage fictif ou réel
que vous appréciez ou admirer
particulièrement
pourquoi est-ce que vous l'admiré et
appréciez particulièrement
je vous invite à y réfléchir
tranquillement chez vous et annoté et à
faire la même chose avec les personnes
que vous détestez vous n'appréciez pas
trop
une fois que vous aurez fait ça vous
allez voir vous allez faire ressortir
des valeurs et des contre valeurs et
avec ça et bien
réfléchissez aux relations que vous avez
eu par le passé qu'ils se sont bien mal
passé à coup sûr il y avait un jeu de
valeurs là dedans parce que les valeurs
c'est ce qui nous réduit et c'est ce qui
nous sépare aussi ont plus vous serez
clair sur vos valeurs plus vous pourrez
les afficher et plus vous pourrez
détecter et attirer les personnes qui
vous correspondent
une fois qu'on a les valeurs il faut
s'interroger sur son action efficiente
que l'on peut nommer aussi mot à mot
d'ozil au mode opératoire identitaire
itératif alors qu'est ce que c'est que
ça et bien ça c'est mon père joël lions
qui a fait cette formidable découverte
que l'on a tous développé jusqu'à l'âge
de saison donc maintenant vous êtes vous
l'avez déjà structuré un mode d'action
qui nous est propre et qui est unique
qui fait notre spécificité
mon père l'a développée à travers les
éclairages qu'il a fait avec ses clients
et puis en allant faire de la recherche
dans les neurosciences
les automatismes le processus créatif la
modélisation de processus en pnl et
d'autres choses encore
et ce mode d'action qui est unique
cet automatisme c'est effectivement un
automatisme et bien c'est un peu comme
les vélos tout le monde sait faire du
vélo vous fait vous ne faites plus
attention à comment vous faites du vélo
vous faites là c'est un peu pareil là
vous le mettez en oeuvre mais vous
faites plus attention à comment vous
faites et du coup vous ne savez plus
mettre de mots sur comment vous faites
si vous mettez des mots sur comment vous
faites vous allez aider vos managers
vous allez dès votre drh à repérer votre
mode de fonctionnement et à mieux
travailler avec vous et à pouvoir dire
en quoi vous êtes
et si figues et du coup à pouvoir vous
aider pour aller là où là vous avez
besoin d'aller cet automatisme et il ya
la difficulté que l'on peut avoir c'est
que justement on le maîtrise
parfaitement
et quand elle maîtrise parfaitement
c'est complètement naturel c'est comme
alban qui fait les triple loots trop
facile pour les autres c'est bien plus
compliqué
rappelez-vous les fois où vous avez fait
quelque chose pour des pour les autres
organiser quelque chose et tout le monde
nous a dit waouh
mais si j'ai mis à ce que tu as fait
vous avez du bois j'ai rien fait long
c'est là qu'est vote actions efficientes
c'est là qu'est le meilleur de vous donc
aller chercher ce qu'il ya là parce que
n'oubliez pas un seul mon départ at war
c'est quand même votre super pouvoirs
alors je vous invite à regarder ces deux
champions du monde en sprint mais un
marathon
tous les deux ont été sélectionnés parce
que ils avaient des points forts dans
cette discipline marathon entre autres
les fibres rapide explosive qui lui
permettent d'aller très vite en pardon
en sprint marathon au contraire des
fibres lentes qui permettent de durer
dans le temps
ces deux sportifs de haut niveau se sont
entraînés pour développer ses points
forts est ce que le champion du monde de
sprint peut devenir champion du monde de
marathon et nous c'est tout simplement
impossible il aurait beaucoup trop de
manques à combler pour y arriver à la
limite champion de france si le niveau
est pas terrible à ce moment là les
champions du monde c'est pas possible
pourtant si on y pense bien ça arrive
souvent en entreprises qu'on demande of
rendement de saint jean tu es nul là il
faut que tu progresses c'est comme
demander un poisson de sauter comme un
rat par un moment donné c'est juste
contre nature donc plus vous allez vous
centré sur vos points forts
plus vous allez pouvoir développer votre
action efficiente plus elle va
s'épanouir et plus les points faibles
finalement on se gommer tout seul la
bonne surprise alors vous pouvez
travailler avec des gens que vous
appréciez parce qu'ils ont les mêmes
valeurs
faire ce que vous aimez en exprimant
votre actions efficientes mais si vous
ne savez pas pourquoi ne serait toujours
pas bien pour ça il faut donner du sens
à ces actions c'est le s du vasco ces
histoires de nous d'un promeneur qui se
baladent et qui rencontre un ouvrier
cet ouvrier mais des briques les unes
sur les autres
mais alors d'une manière apathique
nonchalante sans enthousiasme
curieux le promeneur lui demande mais
qu'est ce que tu fais lille répond pas
tu vois bien je fais ce qu'on me demande
de faire je mets les briques les unes
sur les autres
ok le promeneur continue sa route et
puis il rencontre un deuxième ouvrier
qui fait exactement la même chose
mais cette fois avec un enthousiasme et
énergie une implication qui l'a jamais
vu avant encore plus curieux lui mais
qu'est ce que tu fais là l'ouvrier de
lui répond mais
je construis une cathédrale alors vous
quelle est la cathédrale que vous
construisez qu'est ce que vous voulez
changer dans le monde et finalement
quelle est la meilleure contribution que
vous voulez a porté sur terre pour être
utile lorsque vous aurez répondu à cette
question
n'importe quel projet personnel ou
professionnel que vous mènerez aura du
sens pour vous
enfin il reste deux éléments importants
dont le contexte le contexte un peu
parfum beaucoup de gens ont tendance à
l'oublier a pas il fait attention mais
c'est tout aussi fondamental ça
correspond à l'environnement dans lequel
vous voulez être est ce que voulait
vivre à la campagne à la ville
est ce que voulais travailler dans un
grand groupe une petite structure
quel rythme vous avez vous êtes plutôt
du matin ou du soir pour travailler vous
aimez échangé beaucoup avec les autres
que vous préférez être tranquille dans
votre coin
il ya quel moment ça se passe finalement
quels sont vos besoins fondamentaux et
quelles sont les contraintes importantes
à prendre en compte pour équilibrer
votre vie parce que n'importe quel jeu
passée de haut niveau vous le dire à
vous pouvez vivre votre passion
mais si vous n'équilibre et pas les
choses à un moment donné il va y avoir
une blessure en burn-out maladie
voyant enfin les eaux du vasco avec
l'objectif derrière l'objectif
finalement et bien on va chercher
l'ambition attention pas l'ambition des
hommes qui est de pouvoir qui vont
écraser les autres
mes ambitions généreuse qui va permettre
de transformer les choses
pensez à nelson mandela par exemple s'il
n'avait pas eu cette ambition là
n'auraient pas pu transformer tout ce
qu'elle aurait voulu donc vous quelle
est votre ambition est finalement quel
est votre rêve le plus cher si vous
étiez à la fin de vos jours et que vous
regardez en arrière
quel est ou quelles sont les
réalisations dont vous êtes le plus fier
si vous savez répondre à cette question
vous saurez où vous allez et en sachant
où vous allez vous allez pouvoir
construire votre chemin ça aura toujours
du sens alors finalement le vasco c'est
un peu comme une recette mais bon on a
pas n'importe quelle recette à la
succulente qui va vous permettre de
trouver la quinte de déployer et de
développer la quintessence de vous même
pour ça il vous faut une bonne dose de
valeur un maximum d'accès science
ajoutez y recouvrait le tout deux sens
mettez-y une pincée de contexte et
finaliser tout avec la cerise sur le
gâteau l'objectif en faisant ça cette
réflexion là non seulement vous allez
directement au coeur de ce qui est
important pour être bien dans un poste
et pouvoir déployer mais en plus vous
allez au delà de développer un métier où
des compétences dans un métier vous avez
développé un projet de vie et avec ce
projet de vie
vous serez en plus vous aurez toutes les
cartes à chaque fois que vous arrivez
dans une des trois situations que j'ai
évoqué au départ on se sent pas bien et
que l'on se sent nulle
eh bien vous aurez toutes les cartes en
main pour savoir pourquoi vous n'êtes
pas bien
est ce que c'est parce qu'il ya pas les
valeurs est-ce que c'est parce qu'il
n'ya pas le sens est ce que c'est parce
qu'il n'ya pas l'action efficiente et
vous pourrez ainsi faire les bons choix
en tout cas en toute conscience et
pilotez votre votre vie professionnelle
aujourd'hui en créant et en
développement cabinet conseil en
management qui vise à identifier et à
développer le potentiel des
collaborateurs et des équipes et bien je
sais que je suis là où je dois être
parce que c'est là où je suis le plus
utile
c'est là où je peux exprimer le meilleur
de moi c'est là aussi où je peux choisir
les gens avec qui je vais travailler
parce que je n'aime pas travailler que
les gens qui n'ont pas les mêmes valeurs
que moi je ne supporte pas ça en fait et
c'est là aussi je vais pouvoir aller je
vais pouvoir servir mon ambition qui est
d'aider ceux qui s'en donne les moyens
d'être les champions
le bâtisseur l'entrepreneur le manager
qui rêve d'être d'ailleurs j'en connais
un mage un ami qui est un champion de
l'écriture vous connaissez peut-être je
pense d'ailleurs vous le connaissez
c'est antoine antoine de saint-exupéry
il m'a présenté il ya très longtemps son
fils le petit prince qui m'a livré son
secret et que j'écoute encore
aujourd'hui m'a dit on ne voit bien
qu'avec le coeur l'essentiel l'essentiel
est invisible pour les yeux alors vous
si vous écoutez votre coeur ça donnerait
quoi
merci